this is the first time in history there
are people who were born poor could be
rich first time in history most people
struggle financially but Adele because
they're trying to create wealth with an
idea that was created from the
Industrial Age in the 1950s technology
is the biggest challenge labor is less
valuable because of efficiencies with
technology wanna be happy build a life
not just a business
everybody every single day
oh hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back it lacked a belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how a traditional
education stops you from getting rich
let's figure up with five number one
it's outdated with Dan lock from the
1750s to 1950s we enter at the
Industrial Age Industrial Revolution
something happens something happened
this is the first time in history there
are people who were born poor could be
rich first time in history people were
born poor with no land but they created
something that made them rich in the
Industrial Age machines equals wealth do
more and more of the hard work thousands
of years in the Industrial Age and now
we're transitioning industrial age all
the farmers who were peasants farmers
they have a little shack to live in
right that's how it works
the industry the industrial tycoons and
they say to the farmers hey instead of
working every day seven days a week 14
15 16 hours every day come work in my
factory
you only work five days a week only 9:00
to 5:00
you can take the weekends more than that
if you do that you come don't work in
the farms come work in my factory by the
time to get the 65 I would take care of
you now think about it if you were
farmer working all your life under the
Sun seven days a week someone comes
along make you this offer what would you
say say sign me up let's do it
sign me up and then your life is about
to change forever
and back then Rockefeller Carnegie Henry
Ford JP Morgan they became the richest
people in the world because they created
machines to make mass production
possible and what happens is this in the
first time in history a new class of
people was born that's the middle class
for the first time in history now people
have extra time they have extra income
because before working every day nothing
to do now they've got weekends and
they've got to do something with that
extra time extra income so maybe they'll
go away little bit take a little
vacation so now not two classes you have
what the poor you have the middle class
and then you have the rich another thing
that was born a new revolutionary
concept was born and that is called
retirement retirement was born out of
the Industrial Age I'm gonna work at
this job 95 for 40 years if it's good
I'm gonna retire that's the concept from
the Industrial Age and what happens this
you go home and you talk to your family
so imagine Joe working the factory right
one day the manager comes to Joe and say
hey Joe you are doing a very good job in
the factory doing things you're
productive he's what we gonna do
the manager tells yo why don't I send
you back to school get some education if
you do that you come back I'm gonna give
you a great Joe's like yeah of course
you would Joe working in a factory
manager comes to say get some couple
years education I'm gonna give you a pay
raise so you don't need to work in the
factory are you gonna insert work in a
factory you're gonna manage the people
work in a factory so Joe comes home
sitting down with the kids hey kids you
know the boss comes to me today and he
said if I go to school for a couple
years and then I go back there I don't
need to work in the dirty factory
anymore
I'm gonna get a raise we're gonna make
more money until tell us all the kids
kids if you don't walk one to work in a
factory like I did what do you need to
do you got to go to school the children
are quiet cry oh baby you gotta get good
grades so don't need to like what can
affect you like your dad did these boys
are spiking and the kids like okay dad I
get it I'm mature go to school I'll get
good grades
it's working it's not managing the
people who works the machines couple
years later the manager goes to Joe Hey
Joe you do such a phenomenal job tell
you what why don't you go back to school
for two more years get an MBA then you
don't even need to manage the people who
manage the machine you'll manage the
people who manage the people who manage
the machine and I'm gonna pay your
stubbles what you're making right now
Joe is like what is he gonna say sign me
up went back to school for two more
years graduate now I have that piece of
paper now Joe's making twice as much
managing the people who manage the
people who manage his machine and Joe
goes back and sits down with the kids at
the inner table again
kids holy Sh you know what
nacho don't just go to school for four
years go to school for six years you
don't even need to manage the people
relate to machine you can skip that just
go right up to middle management you can
skip all of that does that sound
familiar that's where the concept was
born from the Industrial Age at the time
the key to success in the Industrial Age
was traditional education if you don't
have a good job you won't succeed and a
really good job it's you're running the
people who are running the people who
are running machines that's a very good
job you work 40 years five days a week
retired they take care of you does that
work for most people anymore most people
struggle financially but it down because
they're trying to create wealth with an
idea that was created from the
Industrial Age
in the 1950s we're in the 21st century
from the nine your family is feeding
your idea they're giving you the formula
for success from 1950s and you wonder
why they struggle and they think let me
if one job is not enough if the formula
doesn't work what do I do I get a say if
that is not enough I get a third jobs
not only do you don't get ahead they get
behind they get left behind also if you
want to have more confidence motivation
and self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the links join under
description below after you practice
Marshall you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self confidence you've got
to separate the vehicle from the outcome
what is it that's gonna truly fulfill
you what is it that's gonna give you
that extraordinary life I always did
everything back pass half words you know
I like to challenge myself and thought
number two the last one before very
special bonus clip is retool yourself
with Tony Robbins I always tell people
the most valuable lesson I got from my
mentor Jim Rohn was I asked my father
worked two jobs
we were always broke we had no money for
food and we lived in a community we
moved to it's just I thought they were
all rich and we're on the other side of
the tracks it was a lower middle class
but compared to where we lived before
these people seemed rich compared to us
and I just didn't understand it and Jim
said to me Tony it's not about the value
of your soul it's about the value of you
in the marketplace and your father's
skills are not that I will he used to
take he was underground parking
attendant and he would take people's
ticket and make change well the research
now shows is being done at Yale's being
done overseas in England as well and
they found that 40% of all jobs they
project in the next ten years are going
to disappear because of Technology it's
gonna be replaced by an algorithm it's
gonna be changed you know all these guys
on Wall Street you're seeing all these
algorithms take over and they're getting
rid of all these traders right it's
changing radically these in these hedge
funds there's three million truck
drivers self-driving cars are here in
the next five years they will be the
standard certainly within seven or eight
years are you gonna hire
I can only work 8 hours a day and
sometimes gets drunk or could make a
mistake when you can buy a machine write
down the Machine and be in a position
where it works 24 hours a day driving
but no one is telling these drivers this
and it's they have to retool now so
technology is the biggest challenge
labor is less valuable because of
efficiencies with technology and it's
going to get better and better for
technology which is scary when you think
about what's going to happen for jobs so
I say to people you got to participate
in your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
of the Bernie Sanders has of providing
free education sounds wonderful but the
education he wants to do is Community
College there are no skill sets in
Community College's today for the most
part that are gonna prepare you for the
economy or a job that's there so what is
that gonna do you're just gonna waste
more money more time we need to retool
ourselves the government's not gonna do
it for you now we have a special bonus
clip from Mark Cupid on how to always be
a student that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question today I
want to know what do you think about
education it's great it's useless where
do you lie let me know down the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe in the comments as well
I focus on things that are AI driven
artificial intelligence driven whether
it's machine learning deep learning
learning neural networks medical
applications but within AI a is a
buzzword that everybody is using right
now you know every in and to that point
you know we as all guys we go back and
it's like 1995 we talked about the
internet and I would say to people back
in 1995 look if you don't understand the
internet you're not gonna be able to do
business and now that's just blocking
the tackling that seems obvious back
then it wasn't right I can even take you
further back to my first company you
know what we did was a company called
micro solutions and we did local area
networks on wide area networks and I
used to walk into companies and say
you're gonna have to hook these pcs
together at some point that'll make you
more productive more effective you know
give you a competitive advantage and
people are like now I just carry this
floppy from this PC to that PC yeah okay
but today we're at the same type of
inflection point with artificial
intelligence you don't have to be an
expert and be able to put together your
own neural network you know you don't
have to know what weights and biases are
but but you have to have more than just
a cursory understanding just like you
have to know the difference between you
know different types of websites and you
have to understand ecommerce if you're
in the e-commerce you have to have a
cursory understanding of how apps work
you're gonna have to have at least if
not more cursory understanding of
artificial intelligence because it will
change everything we do and if the
internet was 10x in terms of change to
business artificial intelligence will be
100x
or more if you go to my house right next
to my bed there's a book machine
learning for dummies you go into my
bathroom there's deep neural networks
for dummies right if you go on there's a
something for dummies in every room of
my house you know they could go to ways
I know but I'm just telling you put the
time I mean I've taken uh you know I
can't even tell you how many hours now I
spend every week if not daily working
like I'll go into Amazon AWS and go
through their machine learning tutorials
don't think to yourself I'm not
technical enough or I'm not gonna get
this or I don't get into this or it's
too much try it get as far as you can
because it's like doing a basic website
and a little bit of HTML just having
done that you feel smarter and you feel
a little bit more confident about this
you know I don't want to be an alarmist
but I'm trying to scare the hell out of
you because it's important
if you want to condition your mind for
success check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when I say jump you jump I'm not
here to have a discussion with you your
mind has the ultimate tactical advantage
over you my mind can be my worst enemy